did you make a conscious decision in
your career i am not gonna
you know to use that old expression [ __ ]
where you eat i am not going to
[ __ ] my co-stars and be that guy i think
it organically just just
just happened um i'll also say this you
know
if you look at at movies if you look in
the history of
films when you see a couple if a couple
like
you say they did a movie together and
then later on they get married right
and they make another movie together
watch the movie
when they're when when they're really
good is the movie before they before it
was ever public that they were getting
together and
when they're on the approach that you're
going oh offset they got a little
honeymoon out
but once they get married you watch that
movie they're like oh they're not near
as good together they were better
when the i can it's the movie when they
met
yes there you go true that's the one
that this thing is sizzling
yeah i mean you know because when i
watch let's say
sandra bullock in a time to kill with
you or i watch um
you know i don't know you know jennifer
garcia i did a lot with kate hudson
kate hudson honestly i go oh i would so
easily be seduced by that
don't you think it's amazing that you
avoided that i am sure
some of these co-stars were attracted to
you and made it pretty obvious
i don't know i've always tried to you
know keep it professional and the people
i worked with i must say
did as well maybe we had certain
crutches on each other at certain times
but we always just kind of kept it
professional
or maybe we were dating somebody
seriously um
outside of ourselves at the time and we
both respected that for the other
is it uh hard to be a married man in
hollywood i mean because
you know i know what fame is it is
difficult because
everybody bows down to you i personalize
hollywood in my
book you know and i write about her want
her
don't need her she is she is a she's a
you know a moonlight tryst um you know
and i mean if you need her
if you want her great you can keep
having a flame with her but
you know fame is a certain amount of
famous for rent
you know and you know my
wife and my family in my mind and so
hard
are non-negotiable and so the
non-negotiable things
in my life when i've watered their
proverbial garden
that's when my garden grew and i
flourished and i became more me
and life felt more vital i you know have
nothing
against certain and i've had trysts
along my way in my own life and some
people can have them forever and you can
peter pan your way through the whole
thing fine um
but it's the non-negotiable things in my
life i've looked at those other things
like oh those are stops not a stage the
most important thing
to me is my is my family
you